everyone i'm your new commanding officer
captain ray holt
speech that was my speech short sweet
hello hello what's your name my name
yes the clay is silent sorry dude but
this new guy is going to be another
washed up pencil pusher
is only concerned with following every
rule and
the patrol guide meet more z robot
captain
engaged here are two pictures
one is your locker the other is a
garbage dump in the philippines
can you tell which is which
that one's the dump they're both your
locker i should have guessed that he's
good i need someone to fill out a lineup
will you be scary terry oh i love being
scary terry
he says what regulatory's thinking this
is taking too long
i'm gonna miss the farmer's market
raymond
those slacks are a knockout come on amy
i found a cold case of ours that
everyone foolishly said was unsolvable
case 52 abx-32qj case 52 abx dash 32qj
is unsolvable or maybe case 52 abx-32qj
is waiting for someone to de-unsolve it
what's case 52abx-32qj
case 52 abx we got to find a way to
abbreviate this thing
oh man my muffin ah
oh my head i'm up in my head and i
stepped on them
on my muffin in my head in my mouth
sergeant you were in the 1-8 with me
though you were significantly
fatter sir they called me cherry titties
because i had large titties yes i
remember
she's got a type which is really anyone
but you
yeah that was my ex-wife's type too for
you
and you and you
what are these these madame are stds
what are you talking about buddy stds
save the dates
for vivian on my wedding ah yes hey just
out of curiosity how many people have
you given stds to
lots like a hundred i'm not angry i
think it's funny
detectives our monthly crime statistics
are due i want all paperwork on your
closed cases by tomorrow
scully you can just write i didn't close
any on a piece of paper you got it
yeah he's a little too serious what do
you think rosa seems cool
seems cool i agree a minivan
you all got a problem with my minivan so
you do not like my ensemble
i'm just concerned that you may find it
hard to pursue a criminal on foot
while wearing man's handles but the
sandals define harvey
he's a sandals guy thank you carlene
your entire life is garbage
baby i've got some bad news someone
painted a giant
penis on our minivan
no you cannot have an suv now those
things roll baby
they roll can you go be depressed over
there
you're bumming out my whole area
wedding's off
and this is what i'm like now life is a
pit well how do you even know he's in a
bad mood
i mean it's impossible to read that guy
this is the most incompetent
worthless report i have ever read in my
life
get your act together or so help me god
you won't live to see retirement
it's like what's that guy thinking you
know release
yeah sweets hello good sir i'd like your
finest bottle of wine please
that will be sixteen hundred dollars
great i'd like your eight dollarist
bottle of wine
please it's from the finest vineyard in
arkansas
oh samesies i met my wife in orgy
well she was leaving in orgy and we
bumped into each other on the street
real meat cute when it comes to shooting
patterns i like to go pb and j
penis brain jaw
you look chipper captain you have a fun
weekend there was a small fire in my
home
i lost many photo albums of treasured
memories
i'm devastated you all right captain
tough weekend i went to barbados with my
husband
we wove hats out of palm fronds and swam
with the stingrays
i've never been happier
right that's the guy you said the lame
stuff about like he's a good listener
i'm sorry
what do you look for in a guy i don't
know real stuff
shape of his ass say it she's like a
sister that's what luke said about leia
hey luke didn't know no one knew can we
please eat
my body is starting to digest itself
terry needs nutrients
who cares what he thinks you're police
sergeant you're a grown man
now take your nap and if i see the
lights on in here i'm gonna be very
disappointed at you
talk to them that's what friends do nope
i'm gonna wait till i'm on my death bed
get in the last word and then die
immediately
that's your plan for dealing with this
that's my plan for dealing with
everything i have 77 arguments i'm gonna
win that way
seems like a bad plan now i have 78.
nice jeans boyle those are surprisingly
low wasted
eyes up here gina i'm more than just a
piece of ass oh
not bad not bad you've been needling
poor peralta so much you practically
made him a new suit
needled him a new suit even when we're
fighting you're hilarious stop it
stop it
[Music]
hitchcock farts non-stop
happy birthday you sly old fox how many
spankings is it this year
ralph please save some charm for the
party she got there boy
eggs in a bag nothing brings me joy
anymore not even food
now i only eat for substance
smart save that for later
oh my god guys
how do you breathe i forgot how to break
it
two in one out all right
give me your hair dryer what are you
talking about don't you carry one in
your purse
have you ever met a human woman hello
detective
is there a reason you're interrupting me
mid-soup
what is going on out there we can't tell
cop stories kevin doesn't find me
charming
and a native english speaker referred to
captain holt is hilarious
i am flummoxed that's a word i learned
for this party and i am it
oh i've caused a problem i
think i am getting a text message
there it is sexy train is leaving a
station
check out this caboose later [ __ ]
is this why you were getting makeup tips
from the prostitute in the holding cell
i just wanted to know how she got such
smoky eyes
turns out it was an std rash thomas
thoughts i have no
thoughts about hummus i'm telling you
this machine is broken
ask me a question is jay-z really your
favorite artist
yes obviously lie see it's busted
is it or is your favorite artist really
taylor swift
no lie all right fine
she is she makes me feel things she
makes all of us feel things
citizen kane is terrible pick a good
movie good call
smart i'll do it
i'll pick a better movie than citizen
kane
no waiting just toasting i want you to
toast now i want to eat toast
give me some toast it was like taking
candy from a baby why are you giving
candy to a baby in the first place
don't give candy to a baby they can't
brush their teeth yes sergeant it is
unwise to give
babies candy i have given you a direct
order to leave
i do not have a problem if i want to
play crazy cupcakes i will play
crazy cupcakes
quasi is a difficult word to say in
anger but
i think i've made my feelings clear
this screw has three pointy sides and
nowhere to screw it in
and there's wheels what kind of
castle has wheels
great news i think i figured out my
persona for this year's tactical village
introducing rex buckingham british
secret agent
ballistics expert and ladies man
yeah cause what woman doesn't love a guy
who's super into make-believe
this whole training simulation is
make-believe we shoot paint at fake bad
guys
it's called acting tell me how i'm any
different than george clooney he has a
sexy voice
i have a sexy voice champagne mountain
range
hugs mountain range i couldn't think of
anything sexy to say
what mountain range is the sexiest
geological feature
no wait sorry deep sea trench
you want to see me sarge yeah come on in
boyle
sorry to hear about your hand thanks
makes it really hard to manipulate my
egg sac
i don't understand why i can't stop i've
never had a problem controlling myself
do you know i love milk no well i do but
it hurts my stomach so i haven't had
milk a beverage i love for 19 years 19
milkless years i've gone but for some
reason i can't
quit crazy cupcakes be appropriate on
three
quietly one two three
now break it up we look weird
don't move as a group you're not
[Music]
gazelles
you